all right griff a lot of moving parts to
this story thank you very much
let's bring in an expert on it tom homan
is a fox news contributor and retired
acting ice director tom good morning to
you good morning
right there at the end um griff showed
that tweet
that kamala harris put out where she
said she spoke to the mexican president
obrador
and thanked him for his cooperation on
migration there it is right there
is mexico cooperating i mean if mexico
was cooperating
would the mexican army be stopping these
people from coming
into our country illegally absolutely
mexico is not cooperating at the level
they did with the trump administration
with the trump administration they had
an agreement he also had an agreement
with all three central american
countries
and one of the first things joe biden
did is killed all those agreements
so mexico did a lot more patrolling
their southern border and their northern
border
they welcomed the remaining mexico
program all that was done away by joe
biden within two days so
mexico is not cooperating with this
country where it should be tom we keep
seeing these images of all these kids uh
the latest this morning is that
five-year-old and six-year-old the
siblings that
were abandoned put over the boulder
rocks on this side of our country
and uh had their mom's phone number and
name written on their arms and in a note
we also heard griff talk about the ms-13
gang member we saw those other two kids
that were dropped over
the gate a few days ago the yemen terror
suspects and then we are learning this
morning
san antonio the governor governor abbott
wants to shut down the facility that's
housing children
because of reports of sexual abuse
family and protective services said
said that they can confirm three
separate reports of abuse here's the
governor we'll get your reaction on the
other side
these problems are a byproduct of
president biden's open
border policies this facility
is a health and safety nightmare
dubai demonstration is now presiding
over the abuse
of children to end this abuse
the biden administration must
immediately
shut down this facility
the children who are in this facility
should be moved to other
federally run facilities where the
federal government has the space
personnel and resources to ensure their
safety
tom your reaction the government
governor is exactly right because here's
what no one's talking about
the bite administration is contracting
with ngos who have no business
running detention facilities i mean
washington examiner just broke a story
last night in the dr telly
about the way these contracts are being
led i mean we have we have family
residential centers that are licensed
that are run by contractors who work
through ice who have
pediatricians on site social workers on
site south
child psychologists these were built for
vulnerable people women and children
and and they're practically empty
because the by administration
calls them for profit prisons so they
rather walk away from
the state-of-the-art facility the gold
standard for vulnerable people they walk
away these facilities leave them half
empty
and they're signing contracts with
federal ngos the person
at ice ahead of now contracts for
detention beds claire mcnulty
is who was an ngo who's an open board
advocate she's making final decision all
detention contracts over and above
the experienced officers who actually
run detention facilities who actually
contracted with attention facilities for
decades
she's making the decision and washington
examiner just broke a story that
some of these contracts are being
awarded to people that work the biden
transition team
the bind campaign they're going to
companies like the endeavor
86 million dollars for hotel rooms
that's 77
000 per alien when we have family
residential centers who were built
for the very same reason taking care of
these children it's ridiculous
they actually if any congressman or
senator is watching this show
i importantly do a congressional
investigation how these contracts are
being awarded
to these open border advocates who have
no business running these types of
facilities
that's why texas is suing uh they're
suing they got to be given a heads up on
this it's running rampant it's happening
on their property on their land
meanwhile don't worry tom you're
overreacting all those reports and all
those miners crying alone without
parents
that's no big deal because speaker
pelosi says joe biden's got this
listen the fact is is that
we're on a good path at the border under
leadership
of joe by president biden we were in a
very bad situation
under the trump administration if you
zoomed in you could have seen her laugh
maybe in the background
is she kidding how did i mean is anyone
buying that
well if dancy pelosi isn't smart at all
we all know that she's probably the
least smart congresswoman ever to be a
member of congress
the bottom line is children are dying
children are being abandoned
31 of women are being raped cartels are
making millions
last march 33 000 apprehensions this
march
170 171 000 it was not out of control
this is a mess it's a chaos built by the
by administration
right and and this was by design this
isn't by accident this is mismanagement
this is open borders
what about joe biden sold out the vice
president was told
hey you do this just like vice president
pence would say hey handle the pandemic
response
she was given this opportunity to show
what she can do
and she has shown that she doesn't want
to do anything she has made one
phone call to mexico she has not visited
the border
she's been to connecticut on march 26th
why not
from the 27th to 31st uh back in
washington then to brentwood california
to visit her
uh heroba stomping grounds over to
oakland and then to chicago to talk
about infrastructure
is that somebody who wants to tackle a
program a problem
so i have a different opinion i don't
want her anywhere near this issue
because you just make it worse look they
don't want to fix this problem
let me tell you what they're trying to
fix and mark my word this has happened
they want to get really good at
releasing people as fast as they can
so there's no overcrowding they'll
ignore the numbers they'll ignore the
release in thousands a day
they're getting sued for texas that's
why texas is suing them
absolutely and they should be suing them
and more states need to sue them
this administration has no intention of
securing this border they have no
intention
of enforcing immigration laws in this
country they've made that clear they
created this crisis
and they're just going to get really
good at releasing people so there's no
overcrowding
they're also getting really good at
making sure that nobody who works for
the federal government
tells the press about what's going on
you know a couple of days ago we heard
that those two yemeni uh guys were
stopped
at the southern border one of them had a
sim card in there they were on the
terrorist watch list
uh and then they took down the press
release so the people would know the
details because of national security tom
and this on the heels of the fact that
uh republicans were able to pressure the
cbp to
admit that since october four other
people on the terrorist watch list have
been apprehended
uh three other yemenis and a serbian so
that makes six that we know of
it seems like the only way that they can
go ahead and continue this ridiculous
it's not
a crisis meme is through censorship
absolutely let me tell you something i
talked to several people in command
of cbp and i'm not going to mention
their names because of course they'll be
in a lot of trouble
that that press release was taken down
because it was bad press for the
administration
exactly they said they didn't click they
didn't clear it properly through dhs
the facts of that press release remain
the facts it was is an accurate press
release
they just they upset the department
because the department wants to control
all press
you know they don't want the men and
women of the board patrol the chiefs out
there talking to
the media they don't want the truth out
american people so much for a
transparent
administration they're hiding from the
american people that the crisis on this
board
that that is a national security crisis
ms-13 members are coming through
yeah real quick when i was live strike
we did operation matador in phoenix
long island you might remember that a
couple years ago we arrested just short
of 500 gang members most of them ms-13
members
42 of the gang members rearrested came
into this country as a uac
or a family group so not only are they
trying to get around the board
joe's part at 1 000 got aways every day
because they're trying to bore throw
assets up with families
they're actually embedding themselves as
uac and family group
and that's why you're having fights at
these facilities that's why you have the
sexual abuse of these facilities
the the gangs and the cartels are taking
advantage it's a humanitarian crisis
and has created a national security
crisis for this country that the bite
administration
is simply ignoring so uh a reporter did
ask jin saki
about kamala harris where is she why is
she traveling around the u.s
when she's in charge of the border and
she's not down there listen to this
is she still working on this and can you
address the perception that she's kind
of
quietly backing off while secretary
mayorkis
is pursuing some trump era policies
first
i would say the vice president was
visiting chicago actually to talk about
covid and the importance of communities
getting the vaccine when it's available
and accessible to them
and so while she was there like many
americans she got a snack
i think she's allowed to do that she is
absolutely an issue that she is remains
committed to the northern triangle which
i'm sure you're aware of but
is not the same as the border
now tom i know you don't want her down
there at the border but what it when you
see all these images of these kids it's
personal to you because you've been to
the border you worked down there for so
long
uh this is a crisis without a doubt
and it's inhumane it's absolutely
inhumane and look
i've said it many times you know you see
these videos for the kids being
abandoned and
a nine-year-old ground the other day
understand
you know there's a video yesterday of
these of these children that happens
every day
numerous times every day on that border
these barbecue agents are dealing with
with abandoned children dying children
and look you've heard i've told my story
many times how many
how many tragedies i've seen on the
border that's why i'm angry because this
can be prevented
president trump had it's on the right
road 70 80
decline illegal immigration killed in
two weeks by this administration
all right uh tom holman uh thanks so
much uh this is not going away
especially because the vice president
was asked to handle it and i and she's
deciding not to she's busy she's got a
letter in her mind